Okay.
[Silence]
I want to see your
Gentlemen,
my gentlemen.
[Silence]
Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
in
authored by
the sixth chapter, the chapter of
reverence of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
[Silence]
Muslim
on the authority of
who narrates that I heard the messenger
of Allah
say whoever swears an oath and then
finds that something contrary to that
oath is closer to tapa than the oath
that he took and they are in conflict.
then he should go with that which is
closer to tawa. The point of this
narration is the very end.
He sums it up and this could this could
as well be a principle on its own and
that is where our prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam says
he should
go to that which is more revering of
Allah that which is more fearful of
Allah that which is more obedient to
Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala says
And do not ever
use Allah and your oaths
as an excuse
to not be just and good with people and
others. He says,
Do not ever use your oaths and do not
ever use Allah as an excuse
to
refrain
from
being
righteous, from righteousness, from
obedience,
from making peace between people and
doing what is good. Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala says this that in no circumstance
will Allah
allow his servant to use him as an
excuse to be bad or to use him as an
excuse to refrain from all that is good.
So when a person swears by Allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala to do something or
not to do something and then something
that is more obedient to Allah,
something that is more revering of
Allah, something that is more closer to
tawa presents itself and the only thing
standing between him and that thing is
his oath. than he is to break his oath
and go with that which is of more
righteousness, more of righteousness.
And this exact thing happened with the
prophet sallall.aii
am and there's a reason for this
narration and Noah doesn't mention it
here in this in this chapter but this
occurrence happened
when the companions
were gearing up for the battle of Tabuk
and the battle of Tabuk the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
had obligated every able-bodied man
who had the ability to join the army was
to join and to go for this battle. And
it was presumed to be be a very
decisive battle yet a very difficult
trek and a very and a very dangerous
battle in itself.
And it was the largest battle to date in
the prophet sallallah.aii wasallam's
time. And so some of the very very poor
impoverished
Muslim
had come to the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam. They had nothing. They barely
had clothing to wear and they wanted to
go and the resources that they were
using had already been stretched to
their limits. And so the prophet
sallallah.aii wasallam said I can't take
you. We we physically don't have the
ability
to take you. We don't have anything for
you to ride on. We don't have the gear.
We don't have the weapons. We don't have
We just physically can't take you. And
they continue to push and prod
and they wanted to go with the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam. These are of the
best of the companions. They had some of
them had never missed a battle with the
prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam.
And so it broke their hearts that they
were unable to accompany the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam in this battle. And
he was was then so strong in
telling them over and over that we can't
take you. We just don't have the
ability. we don't have the room to where
he swore by Allah he would not take them
for them to cease desist
and then
one of the companions came and he
had more animals to ride on more
you know he had the equipment for them
and so suddenly it became possible to
take some of them. And so the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam sent for them
to come to join. So the companions that
were there, they said, "Had you not
swore that you would not take them?" And
so he said,
And so then he said this narration and
in another addition he said
and he is to do the expeation for
breaking his oath. So that little
addition there helps us in knowing the
ruling for someone who does that. You
break an oath in order to go with that
which is
closer to tawa that which is more
pleasing to Allah.
Do you then
do you then do the kaf for breaking your
oath?
The is what
do we know? The
[Silence]
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says
those who break their oath.
The experation for doing such is to feed
10 poor people or to clothe them
or to free a slave. If a person is
unable to do these things,
then he is to fast for three days.
And so
just because the person
broke their oath to do what is more
pleasing to Allah doesn't mean that the
oath is not still binding. The oath
still is binding and the person then is
to do the kafur the expeation. And the
prophet sallall.aii alaihi wasallam in
this instance broke that oath in order
to accommodate those companions to
battle. But then he sallallah.aii
wasallam instructed that whoever did
does such that they perform the
experation the kaf and he perform the
experation as well.
And so this all feeds into the general
command of Allah.
And aid one another in righteousness
and
do not aid one another in sinfulness and
enmity.
Subhan Allah.
[Silence]
in a moment. But